hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast the benefits and burdens of a
saying matched normal tissue when
sequencing cancer genomes my name is
Toby ward and I'm a field application
scientist at personalis incorporated and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we're pleased to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots and sponsored by person Ellis
we're a full solution genomic sequencing
company in menlo park california for
more information we invite you to please
visit personnel esscom we do have a few
important announcements before we begin
this webcast is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the event you can
submit your questions by typing them in
the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window I
will queue these questions as they come
in and we'll try to answer as many
questions as we can by the end of the
presentation if you do have any
technical problems viewing or hearing
this presentation please click on the
support button at the top right of your
presentation window or submit your
problem through the green Q&A button on
the lower left this is an educational
webinar and this offers free continuing
education credits such as pace race CM e
or CEU after the webinar is over please
click on the c/e button located in the
bottom left hand corner of your web page
and you can follow the process to obtain
your credits with that I would now like
to introduce today's speaker dr. Elena
Hellman Elena join personalis over two
years ago as a technical lead in our
bioinformatics science department and
has been instrumental in leading our
development of cancer sequencing and
analysis pipelines throughout her career
at the Broad Institute and at Harvard
and brown university's dr. Hellman has
led cutting-edge projects in cancer bio
informatics including designing tools to
detect genomic rearrangements and
structural variants in whole genome and
whole exome cancer sequencing data today
Elena will discuss the benefits and
burdens faced when sequence data from a
match normal tissue is analyzed in
parallel with a tumor specimen the
learning objectives for the presentation
are first to understand the impact of a
match normal sample on the analysis
pipeline the data filtering and the
database usage for the project second to
consider the burden of secondary
findings when sequencing a match normal
tissue from an individual and finally to
appreciate the definition of actionable
variants in your study design and how
this impacts the results from the
analysis with that
I'd now like to turn it over to Elena
for her presentation Thank You Toby for
the introduction and thank you to
everyone for tuning in with us this
afternoon as we discuss our
investigation of some of the benefits
and the burdens of sequencing a match
normal sample when a saying a cancer
genome now I'll start first with an
overview of person Alice who we are what
we do and describe our proprietary a
sequencing technology I'll then
introduce the different products we've
built to solve some of the challenges
involved in cancer research in clinical
trials and in immuno oncology
applications then I'll discuss our
validation strategy for small variance
using our ace cancer exone and finally
I'll dive into the bulk of our
presentation which is to discuss again
the benefits and burdens of using a
match normal and lastly I'll be happy to
take any questions at the end personalis
was founded in late 2011 by our CEO John
West and our scientific founders
Stanford professors and physicians Russ
Altman Mike Snyder a tool Butte and even
Ashley we hold multiple patents both in
the US and in the UK for our proprietary
ace technology and in 2013 we launched
our first clinical test the ACE clinical
exome which was for inherited and
Mendelian disorders but since then we've
really had a strong focus on developing
our cancer portfolio we have both the
CLIA and a cap accredited laboratory
high performance computing clusters and
our strong bioinformatics and
operational expertise in house now
personalis was founded really to address
the major challenges in next-generation
sequencing our mission is to develop
novel methods to increase the accuracy
at each step in NGS and interpretation
so some of the issues associated with
sample prep and sequencing include
handling of varying sample amounts and
qualities as well as sub optimal
coverage we also spend considerable
effort in optimizing our analytical
pipelines to address some of the
inconsistencies we found that are
associated with the reference sequence
with in perfect alignment and of course
with somatic variant calling we've also
collected a large compendium of
databases and annotation resources
in-house including over 40 public and
proprietary sources and we've really
taken the effort
to standardize and normalize all of the
data coming in from all of these
discrepant sources which really is no
small task so each step of this process
we've focused on creating novel and
innovative solutions to increase the
accuracy and robustness of our
end-to-end NGS solution now one of the
biggest challenges in sequencing today
are the gaps in the inconsistencies with
standard assays like a standard exone so
for example we show here a coverage plot
of the SDK 11 gene using the standard
exome the plot shows all exons
concatenated on the x-axis and the read
depth on the Y and so as you can see
although this gene is sequenced at high
depth in this case an average of over
100 x the standard exome fails to cover
entire exons so variants residing in
these regions would be completely missed
so to address these gaps in the standard
exome we had personalis have developed
our ace technology and a stands for
accuracy and content enhanced we've
implemented a series of both probe
design steps as well as optimization of
sample library prep to augment coverage
and we've built an ace exome design that
works by taking the standard exome here
in blue and adding supplemental coverage
in green and these are combined in an
effort to maximize the genomic content
and provide more uniformity and coverage
which increases confidence in calling
variants in these regions not only do we
target exonic content but we've also
augmented coverage of biomedical
important regions outside of the exon
such as regulatory regions intergenic
and intronic areas as well as difficult
to sequence regions of the genome such
as GC rich areas so when we look again
at our SDK 11 example we have now our
augmented ace coverage shown in green in
addition to the standard exome coverage
which is again in blue and now this
provides 99 percent coverage of exonic
regions in a very uniform manner so with
ace clinically important variants
residing in these hard to sequence
regions can now be identified now we
apply this augmentation to 8,000
medically relevant genes including 1,400
cancer relevant genes across the exome
so for an application such as mutational
load assessment we can use our enhanced
exone for both
broad and highly accurate profiling of
the mutational landscape of the tumor so
these sequencing plots shown here show
ace performance again in green for PR
dx5 and actn for genes both of these
genes have been shown to carry somatic
mutations that may contribute to the
mutational load in these types of
cancers and again variants residing in
green regions would be missed with the
standard exome but with our ace XOM
filling in these gaps we can now get a
true representation of the genomic
landscape for each cancer sample we
apply our ace technology to a number of
different cancer offerings we have an
ace extended cancer panel for both DNA
and RNA we also have a clinical version
of this test for tumor characterization
and clinical interpretation then we have
our augmented a sex home and
transcriptome and all of these assays
are designed to aid in cancer research
and clinical trial investigations as
well as an immuno oncology research now
for this webinar I'll be focusing on two
of our essays more specifically the ACE
cancer gene panel for DNA and our ace
cancer exome so I'd like to delineate
the differences between the two here our
ace cancer gene panel targets over 1400
cancer genes now we designed this panel
to try to assay almost all of the genes
a cancer investigator might be
interested in this includes of course
all actionable cancer genes and hotspot
mutations as well as genes commonly
mutated across cancers as described by
cancer gene census and other large
studies such as the Cancer Genome Atlas
we also target genes that play a role in
canonical pathways of cancer as well as
over 200 cancer-related micro RNA genes
now this large target region is then
sequence to an average of about 500 x
coverage for high depth accuracy now I
can answer a scan sir exome as I've
discussed is a full cancer full standard
exone with the Augmented coverage of
cancer content per our ace technology
the exome is typically sequence to 150
to 200 x depths and is a great resource
for large discovery applications now for
our DNA analysis each sample goes
through an extensive workflow as shown
here in the diagram somatic variants
including snv's
indle's mm vs and somatic cnas are
reported as well as somatic variant
annotations and relevant plots including
genome-wide copy number and mutational
signature and for all of our cancer
assays we think it's important to offer
a complete set of deliverables so we
return all raw data including fast to
you and bam files variant calls and
variant annotation during this talk I'll
be focusing on our DNA analysis but we
do return a full suite of deliverables
from extracted RNA as well and finally
we also return extensive QC reports on
the sequencing data with over 100 read
alignment and variant stats so it's very
easy to determine quickly the quality of
the sample of the sequencing at first
glance as well as the overall somatic
variant calling statistics so accuracy
is very important to us as I hope you
have made clear by now in order to
assess the accuracy with which we call
somatic variants using our assays we
conduct rigorous analytical validation
studies to determine our limits of
detection for the sake of time today
I'll briefly describe our strategy and
results from just one of our validation
studies our ace cancer exome tumor
normal workflow so to determine our
analytical sensitivity first snv's and
in Dell calling we collected a set of 11
well characterized tumor cell lines and
their match normal cell lines we
sequence the DNA from all of these cell
lines with our ace cancer exome and ran
the data through our tumor normal
bioinformatics pipeline we then compared
our variant calls to a set of gold
standard variants to gauge our
sensitivity now what do I mean by gold
variance since gold standard reference
samples are not really available for the
breadth of the assay that I'm discussing
we curated a gold set of somatic
variants using with cosmic verified
events these events were detected in the
cosmic cell line project in the same
cell line as we detected it and was also
verified by two other sources si si le
the cancer selling encyclopedia and NCI
60 or was independently confirmed by
Sanger so in total across these 11 cell
lines there are 875 such gold snips and
19 in dells
now to look at our limits of detection
for snv's and in dells we sequence three
pairs of cell lines and their match
normals to establish a baseline we then
created a series of dilutions to
represent tumor purities ranging from
five percent to eighty percent as shown
for example taking five percent of the
tumor cell line we mix it with
ninety-five percent of the normal cell
line this simulates a five percent tumor
purity and so on up to eighty percent
tumor purity and this allowed us to
assess variants a mutant allele
frequencies down to two point five
percent so we sequence tall 16 delusions
from from this series and ran these
through our tumor normal pipeline using
the corresponding match normal so using
these we calculated our positive percent
agreement PPA and our positive
predictive value ppv at certain mutant
allele frequency thresholds as shown
above so we implemented the validation
strategy I just laid out and ascertain
the following validation numbers for a
sec so overall analytical sensitivity
was ninety-nine percent for smbs and
ninety-five percent for in dulles for
our limits of detection when we look at
all small variants present at a mutant
allele frequency at or greater than ten
percent we have a PPA of ninety-eight
percent and a PPV of ninety-nine percent
if we further break these out by variant
type for snips we have a ninety-eight
percent PPA and a ninety-nine percent
PPV and for in dells we have a
ninety-three percent PPA at a ninety
eight percent PPV again for variance at
MAF greater than equal to ten percent we
also conducted a series of reputable
attea and titration experiments so in
total validation of our ace cancer exome
required sequencing and analysis of over
70 samples and resulted in over seven
thousand snv's and 380 in belz assessed
so this just stresses the fact that more
well characterized reference standards
are needed for large cancer assays such
as ours so having developed and
validated some are assays we then wanted
to see what's the difference in our
pipeline performance depending on
whether we have a match normal sample
available or not now Stokes Toby stated
the learning objectives from this
portion of the webinar to keep in mind
are
first to really understand the
differences in pipelines in filtering
techniques and use of large population
databases necessary depending on whether
or not you have a match normal available
second to discuss the non trivial
considerations of secondary findings
education and consent when sequencing
the germ line and finally we'll talk
about how defining your set of
actionable variants affects your
analysis results so last year we saw
quite a bit of controversy over two more
only sequencing or sequencing just the
tumor without using the match normal for
reference so the current debate over the
importance of the match normal for
accurate tumor genetic profiling
features two main viewpoints on one side
an important paper from earlier last
year concluded that the number the
normal sample is necessary to identify a
germline variants and up to one-third of
actionable mutations they found would
have been filtered out if the match
normal had been available on the other
side other groups have asserted that to
identify key cancer-related variants the
normal is not necessary and is
logistically often difficult to obtain
so these groups continued to provide
exclusively tumor only sequencing and
analysis so we set out to answer this
question how important is the match
normal to do this we collected 87 tumor
samples we're a match normal sample was
available either blood adjacent normal
or both these samples ranged in tumor
type from melanoma to renal cell
carcinoma and in sample type with fresh
frozen ffpe and some cell lines in the
mix we sequence these samples using our
two assays I've described the ACE cancer
panel and the ACE cancer exome and
sequencing data from each sample was
then analyzed using to bioinformatics
pipelines using our tumor normal
analysis and our tumor only analysis now
for our to learn normal somatic analysis
we perform sequencing alignment and
variant calling on the tumor in the
normal separately then instead of doing
a simple subtraction of normal variants
from the tumor we use aligned reads from
the tumor and the normal sample together
in our analysis pipeline to more
accurately call somatic variants and
with the added information of the match
normal we're also able to identify
possible contamination of the sample and
estimate tumor purity more accurately
for our tumor only analysis instead of
incorporating aligned reads from the
match normal we employ a series of
filters and annotations to the variance
called in the tumor to approximate
somatic status these filters include a
variety of population frequency metrics
a large panel of unmatched normals
mutational impact and others and these
filters are unique to the tumor only
pipeline and are just some of the ways
we try to infer matically make up for
the missing match normal an important
part of our tumor on the pipeline is the
population frequency filter large
studies such as the bro institute's
exact database have compiled variants of
over 60,000 individuals across multiple
populations now we've brought these data
in-house normalized across all of these
datasets for accurate annotation and we
use population allele frequency based
thresholds to filter out likely germline
variants now in this diagram I show the
difference at these population frequency
of variants filters make on variant
calling in tumor only mode so without
any filter we see that over 170,000
variants are called across our set of
exome samples if we implement a one
percent population frequency cutoff we
reduce we reduce this number by seventy
percent and an even stricter threshold
of 0 point oh four percent determined
empirically from the frequency data seen
on the right this decreases the number
of tumor only variants to just 34,000 so
the effect of these large databases is
quite substantial now again we ran all
of our samples through both our tumor
normal and our tumor only pipelines and
then we compared the variance detected
by each so in this graphic for each
tumor which is a row on this plot in
blue or the variance called by a tumor
normal analysis in orange are the
variants called by tumor only and in
grey are the variants detected by both
and as you can see here there are many
more variants that are called with our
tumor only analysis that are not called
with our tumor normal and these trends
apply to sample sequence both on our
broad cancer panel on the right and with
our
exim on the left so the few variants
that are unique to tumour normal in blue
here or likely filtered out of the tumor
only analysis because of those stringent
filters that I described previously but
what comprises the much larger
proportion of variants that are unique
to tumour only mode to look at this we
plotted the tumor allele frequency of
variants called by both modes in gray
and variants unique to tumor only in
orange again and it's easy to see that
those extra variants called by the tumor
only analysis are likely germline by
their allele fraction distribution with
peaks of 0.5 and at one now since in
this case we actually had the match
normal available as a reference we were
able to cross-reference the tumor only
variants so for here for each sample
along the x-axis the height of the bar
represents all variants called in tumor
only mode and in maroon is the
proportion of variants that have
evidence in the match normal as well so
you can see here that there's a large
range of tumor only variants that are
actually private germ lines this ranges
from ten percent to eighty percent in
some samples but for most it's about
sixty percent of the variants that are
actually miss called germline so even
with those stringent filters and
population cut-offs that we employ in
our tumor only pipeline many private
germline variants are still being called
when the match normal is not used now
although we see a wide range of
proportion of germline variants when we
plot the actual number of variants on
the right you can see that the number of
variants called in tumor only mode that
are actually germline is very consistent
across the samples despite large
variation in total variance called now
this has important implications for
mutational burden applications because
it shows that somatic mutation alowed
can still be inferred even from tumor
only analysis when the match normal is
not available so we've been looking thus
far at all the variants called across
our entire XOM in our entire gene panel
next we wanted to see how tumor normal
and tumor only analyses differ when we
look at only those variants that are
considered actionable so our first
approach was to this was to use variance
annotated in the clinic
knowledgebase my cancer genome because
they represent a highly curated set of
variants with associated clinical
information so we search for these
variants in our results from both
analyses and across a 57 sample
sequenced on our x own we discovered 34
my cancer genome variance using tumor
normal analysis and 34 such variants
using tumor only and when created a Venn
diagram of these variants we see that
there was a complete overlap so the
tumor only analysis did not identify any
extra or possibly germline actionable
variants in this case so since this was
in contrast with previous findings we
hypothesized that these results may be
sensitive to the set of variants
considered actionable so as we all know
there is a spectrum of what can be
defined as actionable my cancer genome
variants lie on the narrow end of this
actionability spectrum so we repeated
this analysis by looking at filtered
variance in actionable genes as defined
by the jones at all paper 2015 and as
well as by the target database so here
using these broader sets of actionable
genes although there's still high
concordance between both methods we do
start seeing that the tumor only
analysis calls extra variants that would
have been deemed germline if the match
normal had been available in addition to
classifying somatic variants sequencing
the match normal allows you to detect
germline predisposition variants such as
this vhl variant we discovered
suggesting van hippel-lindau syndrome in
one properly consented patient so if we
had not had the match normal in this
case this variant would have been
flagged as putative ly germline due to
its features its allele frequency and
the type of variant suggests that it's
likely a germline and so this variant
would have been recommended for further
drum line testing so tumor only would
not have missed this variant per se but
it would have delayed the syndrome
determination process sequencing the
match normal may also reveal secondary
findings that need to be handled
appropriately the American College of
medical genetics recommends that
pathogenic findings in a set of 56 genes
should be reported this adds
considerable burden on the physician in
terms of proper consent and education
before and after testing and classifying
germline variants in these
57 genes poses additional burden so to
look at this we took 30 matched normal
samples that were sequenced on the
augmented cancer panel which covers 25
of the 56 ACMG genes and 20 matched
normal sample sequence taan the exome we
found almost 1,200 germline variants
called in these 56 genes we then had our
in-house variant classification
scientists go through the filtering and
the classification process for all of
these variants and the result was just
four variants in three ACMG genes
including the vhl as I just discussed as
well as a few Braca one and rafa to
pathogenic variants and not all matched
normal samples are created equal
adjacent normal tissue may often contain
some tumor contamination which can skew
results so here we took a set of 11
tumors where we had both matched blood
and adjacent tissue available we ran our
tumor normal analysis using each of the
normals in turn as you can see there are
some variants called in our blood normal
analysis in red that are then filtered
out when using the adjacent normal
because there was evidence for the
mutation in the adjacent normal so
here's just an example igv plot where
the top panel shows a mutation in the
tumor the middle panel represents the
blood normal which does not contain any
evidence of this clearly somatic
mutation despite the high read coverage
but the adjacent normal on the bottom
panel does have some reads supporting
the variant causing it to be filtered
out in that case so from cases such as
this it's clear that varying filters are
necessary to account for possible tumor
normal contamination so in summary we
sequenced 87 tumor samples using both
are augmented cancer panel and our exome
and analyze these with our tumor normal
and our tumor only somatic analysis
pipelines we found that the proportion
of variants identified and tumor only
that are actually reclassified as
germline when the matching room was
available varies widely across samples
but averages around sixty percent but
the absolute number of variants remains
constant across a variety of samples we
saw that when you strictly define a set
of actionable variants both tumor normal
both tumor normal and tumor only perform
equally well
we find that the burden of germline
classification for secondary findings is
high and the match normal itself
presents its own challenges as we showed
with the adjacent normal contaminated by
tumor so in conclusion we offer a third
view in the tumor profiling debate we're
both tumor normal and tumor only
analyses are viable solutions so when a
normal sample can be obtained it should
be analyzed together with the tumor so
that somatic and germ line calls can be
differentiated cancer predisposition and
secondary germline findings can and some
should be reported but care must be paid
to proper classification consent and
education when a normal sample is not
available which is often the case in
clinical settings sophisticated filters
and annotations can be used to
approximate somatic status although many
germline variants will still come
through as we saw today but putative
germline variants can be flagged for
further testing and finally as you
evaluate different methods it's
important to keep in mind that to do a
fair comparison you need highly
optimized by informatik pipelines for
both two more normal and tumor only and
how exactly you define the set of
actionable variants you analyze really
affects your results thank you all for
your attention and I'll hand it back to
Toby for the Q&A session Elena thank you
for that informative presentation before
we get started on the Q&A session I'd
like to remind the audience how to
submit your questions you can submit
questions by typing them into the Q&A
box which can be found by clicking on
the green Q&A button at the lower left
of your presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can so
our first question is having said all
that do you recommend submitting a
normal with the tumor specimen that's a
good question so in the end the answer
is it depends it depends what your or
your application is so if you are
looking at a very refined narrow set of
actionable hotspot cancer mutations like
we showed a normal might not actually be
absolutely necessary for that refined
set of variants and similarly if you're
looking at mutational load are
mutational burden and applications such
as this again a normal might not be
necessary to
assess relative mutational load across
samples however once you start to
broaden your definition of actionable
and you're interested in in mutations
that are not as well characterized
that's when a normal is extremely
important as we saw to really
differentiate between somatic variants
and germline variants thank you question
number two says you talked about snips
SMBs and in dells so how does the match
normal affect somatic copy number
analysis great question we are working
on that current Lane so we'll let you
know thank you so when you described the
ACE technology you mentioned optimized
coverage of the genes on the panel and
on the exome how was this accomplished
yeah so we accomplished that with our
ace technology that accuracy and content
enhanced technology that I mentioned and
that consists of both additional probes
and optimized probe design as well as
optimized sample library prep techniques
and we utilize a few different protocols
in order to achieve uniform coverage
across even those hard to sequence
regions of the genome like gc-rich thank
you next question says do you require a
match normal for your clinical tests so
we we do take in normals for our
research products but for our clinical
tests currently we actually don't
require a normal okay so the next
question coming in says how do you
differentiate possible tissue mosaics
versus true tumor mutations yeah so I
mean we depends on the match normal you
have if you have a blood normal then you
can differentiate using that and that's
a good question though we have thought
about this in the past and if you have a
blood normal you wouldn't expect the
mutation to be in the blood as well so
that's a good way to differentiate that
mm-hmm thank you so let's see I think we
have one more question so some other
reference standards do exist such as
those available from horizon discovery
why couldn't you just use those for your
optimization yeah so horizon does have a
few reference standards that are great
they each contain a few important cancer
variants and we have you
those but we we felt that for our large
sa to really assess how we do across the
entire essay it just wasn't sufficient
so that's why we had to go about
creating our own cell line mixtures and
trying to curate our own gold set
ourselves in addition the the horizon
standards they don't give you all of the
variants that are present so it was hard
to assess specificity and ppv using
those standards the next question says
can the ACE exome analysis pipeline be
used for neurological panels as well or
what the parameters have to be tweaked
to accommodate for that type of sample I
believe I mean we have our ace exim four
that's used for neurology and is used
for more drumline things I don't know if
this question pertains to particular
cancer related yeah I've a question but
we do have a research XOM that's used
for non-cancer applications as well
thank you okay so that was our final
question in closing I'd like to once
again thank lab roots as well as the
sponsor personalis we invite you to
visit personnel skaam for more
information about our company and our
capabilities I'd also like to thank dr.
Hellman for her informative presentation
as a reminder you can get your
continuing education credits by clicking
at the bottom of your web view and thank
you and we'll see you next time